welcome to this video playing a blitz
game and the guys not playing and always
playing and this is actually very well
known player have a look this is eugene
torah a true chess legend his um been
the number one play off the philippines
form for ages basically I'm to the point
where Wesley so um became the number one
and this has only been a couple of years
ago yeah Tori has participated in I
don't know maybe around her 20 chess
olympiads or so it's a just just great
he also played a really good Olympia
term last year in Turkey alright so on
let's see what's happening here we have
one um at ron paul scheme and I'm played
with them quick d5 a very solid approach
yeah he it seems that he tries to
prevent f5 but I think I can play it
anyway Queenie five does 95 Queen F 595
attacking the bishop I I need to play
what I want to do is I want to get the
knight to f6 I don't want it on b6 or
something he can play um you know I
thought I move that Texas like in
Nigeria return ok so i guess it long
this is some of course quite quite
ambitious i also have some ideas on my
own with p 5 p for something like that
okay be five is probably just going now
Bishop d3 and then it's not so clear
what my continuation is
is maybe going G for any way without any
preparation hmm ok my idea is a four and
then be five B 4 B 3 so this is known
from the Queens gambit declined this
kind of attacking idea yeah my my
intention was to just ignore this if he
plays out g takes a 5 ok you can have
the spawn
okay so he wants to take em with a piece
on at five yet the sudden he makes lots
of sense should I go here I can can I
ignore this should I ignore this yeah
okay come on I need to get something
going him okay so yeah I have a half be
three okay first should I capture here
Knight f6 Queen f6 queen of five is not
not great okay this was the idea anyway
opening up the position alrighty cannot
it cannot take twice on b3 now as
probably some things hanging here you
phone line okay yeah he's got many idea
can take on f6 take on h7 I didn't
really calculate I need to open lines
him anything thinking about something
else is just a waste of time this is
just a complete race situation where
material doesn't really matter I'm not
sure what is what you should play now
cannot take f six th-7 of the queen is
hanging and it's always needs to got the
the bishop and you also cannot allow me
to take but isn't this just good for
black yeah I think this is just good for
blank it's just it's just a big attack
so if it takes with the Queen okay it
didn't yeah yeah I also have bishop a 6
& a 6 which isn't too bad but is it good
now it is good I just detect the special
of this night and Queen d2 is not very
attractive
because it it takes away oh wait wait
wait this I shouldn't should be too
quick taking the Queen if i take with
the Queen at some it's really far away
from the main cause of action no no no I
need to go any to have Queen 85 at some
point go to go to the a foul enter and
see that you that that I checkmate
checkmate him ok so I could what I
thought I was just taking and check
kingly to Bishop before on Bishop c4
hmm i'm not i'm not entirely sure okay
cannot I don't have enough time to to
calculate the jump to the end this is
certainly a strong attack but maybe not
the absolute best way to play we see in
Queen a 50 pages the the plan but maybe
there was a forcing win this is very
likely but is all tied up really and
it's a while until he's got some some
serious threat and now it's rook takes
be one you cannot take with the night
and I can move the Queen now forgot
about that turn
I know I what think of course he can do
that but it's it's just one check here
I'm check I can I can escape I favor can
I can just escaped check check check all
the way here and check yeah ah is it a
perpetual maybe it is I can go all the
way to be aid
community six can see yet now Jackie
always needs to check of course so
there's some way to can't play this for
when Quincy seven or something Jack a
Jew at the end
okay this is very risky time watching
the position here is winning it takes
see how you were going to look see to
mate look at it to Bishop d3 this is
what I saw check check check who what
again recent lines well yeah I probably
missed something before I'm not sure
that I I needed to allow all this the
Queen invasion somewhere around here it
looks like like like should just win
I've done maybe this isn't the case okay
Bishop a success all right according to
the cheetah and he in fact Queen f6 but
is this bad it seems to be substantially
worse I don't really understand why
computer wants to play why is this
computer wants to play this game let's
see here and now it plays Bishop c4 I
see I see now I'm threatening Queen f5
Queen f5 and look a one check made now
this is a nice line so this is what the
compounds to do yeah so and now now the
computer wants to play Queen f3 which I
don't understand at all what is twin f3
Wow what is the smooth doing all Queen
f3 it wants to play rook d2f one
very mysterious I don't even I don't
understand the threat to you is it a
five or some other see 5 or something if
I do nothing new for this black doing I
look ahead ok 8 and ok too yeah of
course it's a strong attack but ok I
didn't think about we have six Queen I
think GF looked totally normal to me and
this is probably a strong attack as well
but ok here check HERE Bishop before
what if one we should be home here
Andrew k 1 but we get to the same we get
to the same position if form and now
taking on be one wins yeah yeah yeah ok
I understand I need to take first this
is very interesting I need to take first
now because now i'm just-just right on
time he cannot play this because Jack
wins the Queen after night be one so it
doesn't have a movie if you play
something like this this is just too
late because Jack I had this young ok so
in the game I played here if I had again
rook takes be one wins and after that he
still has the smooth and ok look takes
be one still wins Jack ninth eggs and
Queen a one yeah why is this winning
because of look II to yeah of course
it's a strong attack but really if he
takes here what is the mate ah this is
your mate this is very nice ok technique
this is the mate ok of course I couldn't
I couldn't find that very cute very cute
ok very interesting game I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching